juste un Trudeau ne regrette rien
nommé oui pourquoi
d'avoir des gens qui peuvent parler pour
la communauté et c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît très bien la communauté
musulmane y compris au Québec quelques
jours après sa nomination à titre de
conseillère spécial du gouvernement dans
la lutte contre l'islamophobie les
écrits d'Amira el ghawahabi soulève
l'indignation loi sur la laïcité de
l'État est adoptée en juillet 2019 - 2
mois après l'adoption de la loi 21 et
l'écrivait dans une chronique dans le
Ottawa Citizen malheureusement la
majorité des Québécois semble être
influencée non pas par l'État de droit
mais par un sentiment anti-musulman à la
demande de Justin Trudeau est la
clarifier ses propos vendredi sur
Twitter et l'écrit je ne crois pas que
les Québécois soient islamophobe mais
commentaires passés faisaient référence
à un sondage au sujet de la loi 21 je
travaillerai avec les partenaires de
toutes les provinces et régions pour
m'assurer que nous combattons
directement le racisme les explications
qui ne passent pas les conservateurs
réclament sa démission on estime qu'elle
n'a pas sa place dans cette ne le fait
pas le ministre québécois responsable de
la laïcité Jean-François robertge
demande kotawa la démerde de ses
fonctions mais sa collègue la
vice-première ministre Geneviève
Guilbaud qui assistait hier à la
cérémonie de commémoration de la tuerie
à la grande mosquée de Québec ne va pas
aussi loin mais je trouve que c'est
déplacé c'est très déplacé ce qu'elle a
dit faut pas laisser planer que les
Québécois seraient des gens
systématiquement racistes j'ai demandé
une rencontre avec Madame el ghaouabi
avant de trancher le chef du Bloc
québécois lui demande à s'entretenir
avec la principale intéressée mais il se
pose des questions sur les intentions de
Justin Trudeau je pensais que c'était le
premier ministre du Canada Justin
Trudeau travaille hardiment à donner
mauvaise image mauvaise Price et à
culpabiliser les Québécois en les
prétendants racistes xénophobes ou
islamophobe pour les néo-démocrates le
débat éclos
c'est clarifié moi je pense que non on
peut tourner la page la question demeure
sensible même au sein du caucus libéral
où le lieutenant du Québec de Justin
Trudeau Pablo Rodriguez Sidi blessé et
insulté par les propos d'Amira el ghawa
be la principale intéressée n'a pas
répondu à notre demande d'entrevue ici
Valérie gainage réseau Canada
Ottawa